in fact xiaomi doesn't only make phones
with a whole bunch of Lifestyle products
that'll up your hygiene game and get you
through your day-to-day with ease the
xiaomi air purifier Pro 4 is a handsome
looking air purifier with smarts to
match use the xiaomi home map to adjust
settings timers and turn it on to pop
your house with 8 330 liters of clean
air per minute and you can see how clean
your air is with your OLED display
the me robot vacuum up 2 Pro is the
perfect tool for people like you and I
it mops up coffee stains and soy sauce
with hello vibrations 10 000 vibrations
per minute and its microfibers that
helps with even penetration of water and
quick drying the xiaomi small bed 7 Pro
is a stylish SmartWatch with 12 days of
battery life tons of watch faces onwards
running courses and so much more on its
beautiful 1.64 inch AMOLED display
lastly the redmi Box 4 pro has 36 hours
battery life with 9 hours of listening
on a single charge 43 decibels of noise
cancellation ensure that you're able to
hear the Hi-Fi quality of the Dual
Dynamic drivers peacefully and
comfortable too with their ergonomic
design